[Music]
eric is with us in tampa florida hi eric
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks dude thanks again thanks for
having me sure what's up um
my question it's a pretty simple one uh
i'm considering well i'm gonna move home
back to michigan and be closer to family
but i'm curious i want to get a condo
and i don't know if there's a good
ratio or a rule of thumb when it comes
to how much i should spend or how much
how much is too much when i consider
hoacs
uh if if they if they are
disproportionate to
what the payment would be on the normal
condo i mean if you've got a a a condo
that the normal payment is 1500 on and
the hoa fees are are a thousand bucks a
month then that's disproportionate i'm
going to want to know that there's
something screwed up right
so
other than that what i would be most
concerned about is i probably
since you asked i i probably would look
at if i'm worried about it at all i'd
probably look at the annual budget on
the on the hoa
okay i'll give you an example i had a
condo that i owned
we bought a condo in knoxville because
our kids were in school down there and
we were going back and forth with
football games to see see kids in school
and uh they were not setting money back
to replace the parking lot and the roofs
and so when it came up we got hammered
with special assessments but the hoa
fees were strangely low
okay you see so you have to be concerned
you kind of have to be concerned the
other way too
right is that something that i can
request from the hoa before making
absolutely you can have the agent pull
the budget for you
what's the annual budget look like and
make sure that they're if you're going
into a condo make sure they're setting
aside for capital improvements whatever
the the condo is responsible for which
is usually the exterior pieces
it'll be uh some landscaping it'll be
roof siding uh parking lots those kinds
of things and make sure they're setting
money back for replacement because if
things got a 10-year life you ought to
be setting this out a tenth of it every
year right it's a sinking fund is what's
called and so
and if they're not doing that that's a
concern the other thing the other side
of it is are they just going cray-cray
because they're they're
you know they're spending too much
because they're trying to be something
they're not they're trying to build the
taj mahal uh this dinky butt little
condo you know or something like that
and so you you just you got to check it
on the other side are they over spending
on something and then that'll tell you
how well it's being managed i would
worry about one that didn't have
professional management assisting the
homeowners operated board if the
homeowner operated board does it by
themselves that's where you get into the
most
uh bizarre stories that i've gotten into
anyway on hoas and properties we've
owned
i hate them i hate them uh most of them
are just a total pain in the butt
it's like local politics those that
you're talking about you know
larry the control freaks in charge like
student body government and junior high
school it's just it's just yuck yeah the
guy who really shouldn't
should not he he's the you know he
hasn't got anything else to do he gets
put in charge that's exactly he's
bizarre yeah just never he's running
around checking everybody's bushes for
the correct diameter
and it just just makes me want to shoot
you're in my yard again harry get out of
my yard
you know
oh god it's just that guy but that
that's the stuff i can't stand in those
things and
um
oh i don't even want to talk about it
but anyway the um yeah that's the stuff
you got to be careful of is how's the
politics of the thing running uh how's
it operated as a professionally managed
are they saving too much for something
are they spending too much on some
things are they not sending anything
back on the other because you'll get a
special assessment later or you'll get a
reputation of the roofs are all leaking
and they don't have the money to fix
them and they didn't do a special
assessment so now the condo project gets
a bad reputation or the home the
subdivision gets a bad reputation
because the pond is always full of scum
or whatever and uh then you can't sell
the house because the hoa becomes the
the detriment
to the the value of the property and um
yeah you got to watch it i'm you know by
and large it's just um
a bunch of little uh
most of it's not a problem but
except just the the emotion around it
and being told what to do in a house i
paid for and stuff like that that just
i'm just i guess i'm a libertarian or
something or whatever you call that i
don't know what you call it like like i
own this so leave me alone kind of i'm
that guy whatever it is i know i'm an
old guy get off my lawn that's what i
said yeah that's exactly what i had
harry quit measuring my
exactly
bushes
exactly who i am i'm that guy
except i'm the clint eastwood version oh
for sure
for sure he's packing i feel like i hear
that yeah
you're in the rocking chair yeah
man yeah i i just it's um
i still don't understand like we got we
cut a tree down uh on one of our
properties and i found out that
apparently that was illegal yeah you
didn't read the fine print i wasn't one
attacked to the tree oh and i was all
confused i thought i owned the tree it's
a good point you know but the the tree
nazi lady came out and god almighty oh
man
there you go you know and that's
ultimate i think i could have shot her
dog and i probably got in less trouble
i don't know that one's pretty dicey
[Laughter]
probably neither one's a good idea but
what do i know